well the storyline albert going into
this season i think would be
can tom brady repeat can the buccaneers
go back to back
does he have one more left in him but
that doesn't seem to be
on everybody's top of mind here in july
as we head into camp next week
it's all about aaron rodgers and it's
all about his status with the green bay
packers
report coming out turning down an offer
to become the highest paid player in the
nfl
what does that say about his future in
green bay and where do you see him
playing football next year
i mean quite honestly i don't think it
tells the same thing we didn't already
know um
you know the packers were out there i
talked to brian good who comes to jam
for the packers right before the draft
um or right after the draft
about it and um you know like they the
attackers have never had an issue with
the idea that
they might have to adjust to aaron
rodgers contract
um you know because he you know played
an mvp level last year actually won the
award and
um you know and and and the market has
moved in his position significantly and
so
yeah i i don't think the contract was
ever
the issue here um i think the issue was
communication
i think the issue was the approach the
team's taking i think the issue is
what aaron rodgers wants um the last few
years of his career
i don't think it was ever money now i
mean
you know would it help at the end of the
day um if the packers
showed commitment to aaron rodgers
monetarily
and showed you're our guy and we're not
pulling the rug out from underneath you
um and going to jordan love prematurely
um
in you know what they put in front of
him contractually yeah that would help
but yeah i don't think that that's the
money again that's about
you know the commitment to rogers and
where the organization's going to be and
how the organization's going to operate
over the next couple of years
albert brewer joins the show senior nfl
reporter for the monday morning
quarterback ben lines in for rich the
rich eisen show
but albert it would seem to me that if
aaron were solely focused on winning and
wanting to find the best situation that
gave him a chance to go to another super
bowl it would be in green bay
where he was a half away at home last
year from going to play for another
lombardi
but if it's not about money it's not
about winning
what is he asking for what does he want
well so i think what started this was
the communication issue and the fact
that he found out about
you know jordan love and his interest in
jordan love while they were on the clock
like
i think that you know i think that
basically sounded the alarm for him you
know made him feel like right or wrong
that he was on the clock at the
quarterback of the packers
um you know and i think that there's a
sort of undercurrent of that
um in their relationship since and so
i think it's you know the relationship
between rogers and the front office i
don't think it's so much the coaches but
the relationship between
rogers and the front office was strained
by that you know and then i think the
other piece of it
um and i think that this goes for a lot
of the quarterback movement over
here um is what happened in tampa
and you know it's not just that tom
brady got an operation built around him
it's not just that the bucks are
building on his timetable and with
um you know a certain sense of urgency
is that it worked
you know it's that like i think for guys
that were knocked out of the playoffs
last year
at that position that are older they're
looking at it and they're saying give me
some of
that and you know i i think
not only do they want it because they
want to have organizations centered
around them
um but i think they also want it because
they know that's what they're up against
and having to get past the buccaneers
the next couple of years
and so i think for you russell wilson
for your aaron rodgers for even a
matthew stafford
part of the reason there was case
rattling this year at the quarterback
position
is because of uh you know what we're
seeing
and where the sport may be going now and
you can call the lebronization of the
sport
um if you want and i would argue that
darren rodgers in
great situation right now in green bay
um to go and win a championship you know
but
i can also see where other quarterbacks
want what brady has and
feel like they might have a tough time
competing with an organization that's
operating on the sort of
short timetable that the bucks are
operating on i'm glad you mentioned
player mobility is what i was going to
ask you next because i feel like the nfl
has done a lot to try to prevent players
star players
from changing teams in the prime of
their career it becomes difficult it
gets played out in the media
gets stretched out for a long time the
nba's had a lot of success
with it i think it's it's inspired an
entire generation of fans to follow
players and not simply their local teams
do you think that this rogers situation
will be a watershed
moment for the nfl moving forward and
we'll see
uh more fluid player mobility especially
at the quarterback position
i think um i think you used the wrong
word there
um he said especially the quarterback
position i think some degree might be
only at the quarterback position
um and i mean well you know with rare
exceptions for players that are
considered you know sort of generational
talents at their spots
um i don't think a lot of players can
pull this off i just think it's too hard
to make money in the nfl
and i think too many guys are in the
spot where it's you know
if i can find a way to make money i'm
going to do it any way i can do it
and i don't want to rock the boat
because my earning power is fleeting
um you know the nba and the nfl are
different that way in that
nfl players careers last longer don't
last as long
and um they're going to have a harder
time finding their way to the top of the
market just because
there are more nfl players than there
are nba players they're more replaceable
than nba players are and so
you know i i think you might see
more players try this and
i i think the i think the
the issue though is that there are very
few players that have the leverage to
pull it off
and you know really the guys who have
the leverage to pull it off are guys who
have a lot of money in their bank
accounts
and the kinds of guys where teams can
look at it and say
that's the kind of guy that i'm willing
to go all in on and give up big time
draft capitals and go and get and so
um yeah i mean i i think you could see
more of it the quarterback position
and maybe a couple other spots um where
you know players are valued at that
level but i don't think that this is
going to
change the way business is done in the
nfl for say
your your your just your normal really
solid even pro bowl linebacker
or your really solid pro bowl guard i
think
if there is change that comes from this
i think it's going to be
sort of reserved for the elite of the
elite hey you watched all the way to the
end
thanks for that watch more right here